[Music]
debbie starts off this hour in new york
city hi debbie welcome to the ramsey
show
hi um hi dave hey what's up i hope
you're doing well i am how are you
i'm okay i'm okay
um
so my question
um i know that i'm very new i
but i've already cut i've already closed
six credit card accounts good for you
and
yeah so and i have a question although
it's a little far in the future
considering where i am with my debts
but you say to put the to do the three
to six a month emergency funds from what
i've heard from your show and from
reading your books
after you do all your desks other than
your mortgage but i don't have a
mortgage because i rent my husband and i
we rent
and
so my largest debt is a 93 and a half
thousand dollar student loan
and i'm kind of my other debts to get
them all together the debts are like
almost 190 000.
besides what i already just cut up
anyway so my question is i'm just
concerned that they'll take me for i'll
never get to the emergency fund or it'll
take way too long if i do the student
loan before i do the emergency fund my
husband you know his income isn't 100
steady because he you know
self-employed and um
you know and what do you guys remember
it's all taken up on my debts
what do you make a year
household income um i actually looked it
up last year i made
thirty
106
what did he make
that i don't know exactly i just here is
income movie varies it's less than mine
right now um it used to be more um he
has a steady thirty thousand dollars and
then it goes up and down depending upon
how much work he has and it's uh
and um but i know exactly what does he
do
he's an electrician um
and uh why is he not covered up in work
[Music]
yeah my husband is a lot older than me
um so he's 84. so he doesn't really do
the work himself and
he just you know backs up other people
basically yeah and so
so how old are you he does that so he
doesn't like you know so he just gets to
like a small fee you know so how old are
you
59 okay cool
all right good for you well i'm glad
you're attacking this
and in general
there's a power to focus so you've got a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
plus or minus income
to attack almost two hundred thousand
dollars in debt
yeah
ouch
what was your student loan for
nursing and that first the two loans the
original nursing degree then i
this would be my stupid
i went for the masters but i did it as a
bridge program because i had a
bachelor's so now the masters did need
buckets no everyone wanted me to have
the bsn but my bachelor's is in another
thing so i feel so i have a borrower's
defense case now for that part for that
part of loan i have a borrower's defense
case active and right now
i i'm in forbearance because of that and
even when everyone else has to pay back
their loans because the pandemic freeze
is ending
i still don't have to pay until they
decide my case right
um
so right now i'm not even focusing on
that at the moment and i don't know if
i'll win or not and if i do i'll still
have for the original degree right um
which is like so you are you are a nurse
today
i'm yeah i'm a school nurse i mean i'm
an rn but i work in a school okay all
right
i have a quick question on that dave are
you maxed out with with the
the degree you have and experience you
have as a nurse are you maxed out or
could you make more than than the 106
um i tried to get
back in the hospital
and no one would even interview me i
didn't ask you that i'm just saying are
you maxed out in the marketplace there's
something else you can do with an rn
that makes you more than you make now
not that i'm aware of no i mean
but i couldn't do that because i don't
have the experience
in anything that you can get an np in
because i spent most of my time in the
school yeah so i can't i can't go for a
postgraduate certificate program as a
nurse practitioner because of that right
and i also work for my husband's
business at night you know it's like i
work for i work all day in the schools
his business doesn't make enough money
that you have to work for it much
yeah well sometimes it's busy sometimes
it's not and he also doesn't even know
how to turn on a computer so i have to
do everything computer related even his
emails
like you know like some people either
owe me emails i have to yeah but if all
of that's making you five dollars it's
not worth it you might hire somebody to
do that it'd be cheaper if you could
make more money doing something else but
so don't get caught in that so the
answer to your overall question is uh
you have a really high
i mean you're in a pretty deep hole
with a medium-sized shovel
and that's what we always call it the
shovel to hole ratio what's the ratio of
your income to the debt and you have 130
to 150 000 household income
with 200 000 in debt
and so if we paid a
fifty thousand dollars a year on it it
takes four years
if we pay seventy five thousand dollars
a year on it it takes three years
and that means that you're living on
beans and rice rice and beans you're
living on nothing scorched earth below
nothing in new york city to be able to
pull that off and
that's why we're scratching around here
because if we can add 20 or 50 000 to
this equation on income it gets you out
of debt a bazillion times faster
and whether or not to save for the
emergency fund is really not going to be
your problem your problem is you have
got to for the first time in your life
address this ridiculous debt situation
because it spiraled out of control on
you
and so i mean
we can argue about or discuss the
theories of baby step one being a
thousand dollars or do you move baby
step three ahead but none of that
changes the fact that you have 200 000
in debt
and you've still got to address that
and so
you know if you say i'm going to save
ten thousand dollars for a little
emergency fund before i move on to my
student loan fine go ahead and do that
but it doesn't it doesn't address the
issue
the issue is you've got to do something
pretty radical and begin to attack this
debt at a level you have never
considered before
and uh and that's what we're outlining
is this intensity and this level of
sacrifice
to be able to be free and be clear
because the last thing i want you to be
is 10 years older and still sitting here
and he's gone and he's gone to heaven
you know that's not what i want for you
and so i want you to have a better life
than that and it's going to involve
some you know it's a big mess so it's
going to involve some big changes and
some big sacrifice to get there
this is not a little mess
so i'm honored to have you in my
audience thank you for calling debbie i
know it's scary and i want you to feel
free to call us anytime we'll always
help you
you keep fighting it i think you can do
it but buddy i mean you got a mountain
to climb girlfriend